what's up reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch all
three New Zealand deck ads apparently
these are real ads I don't know what it
deck yeah for like a deck for your house
topper war to your video quest for a man
named Andrew Nickerson recently became
one of our top eight all the fuss is
about
[Music]
[Music]
put on your penis keep in it Roger at
the time I turn 40 my dick became soft
and spongy and I knew my wife will
different side
[Music]
[Laughter]
No
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you can't just rock up to a meeting with
your D before I show my dick to anyone I
took it on the book of screen I can find
and then spend up to two hours poring
over every detail of my own almost
that's the longest one this office
everyone's eyes one they get the feel of
monkey and I like was off because
they've seen the dick like yours before
but with Schafer's new zealand style of
deep presentations you'll virtually slap
them with your dick
Jim wake up what was I talking about
good Nick it's a good sign of just
following along he must be a bit of a
director Hitchcock cam huh presentations
try out Deeks they're easy because
they're not hot
who is the original create all credit
goes to the Key of Awesome okay wait
there's a pin comment here I gotta read
this yep there's a real and with a crazy
story behind them these are the infamous
infomercials he's really real the
infomercial that Schafer's used
advertised their lineup of dick
maintenance products but quickly went
viral worldwide as you can see on
YouTube only to be mocked for the
accident voice are you talking about is
clearly straight-up [ __ ] right
especially the last one okay so not real
its interpretation copy attention to
multiple museum retail advertising firms
who have roughly cut all advertising
deals from Schafer's due to
unintentional how is the last one
unintentional especially the last is
like the mall the first one you're like
maybe but the second one you're like oh
another yeah it's fun to watch someone
else rub your dick the third one is so
like you know this joke almost goes too
far in the third one where you're like
okay yeah Ronde out beyond the innocuous
deck itself like he's in zipping his
pants and from the secretary it doesn't
seem way no this big up it has to be fit
Martin Schaffer filed for bankruptcy in
February 2017 following the collapse of
his deck maintenance business three
months prior after spiraling into a
state of depression the crystal meth
addiction Marty was thankfully able to
get a life back on track in today works
as a drive-thru operator in Oakland KFC
oh oh God oh my no this can't be real I
know this is a whole video just googling
gonna be factories
is real and I'm losing our minds over
this
it's like Marty Schaffer one eternity
later
everything's saying like these were
banned commercials lights no there's no
way this could be real maybe the first
one was real and then maybe they got
banned and then they just leaned into it
and decided to release these viral E's
either way someone comment below with
the true story about this is gonna drive
us both insane this is hilarious yeah
this was me this is really really funny
it's weird how they just they beat this
joke to death this is totally blunt
there was no way like they made a for
fun it just wouldn't be funny it is one
whole joke just completely making fun of
how New Zealand people pronounce deck
like the word dink
so now it was consistently funny for all
seven minutes I think it's especially
because you know the different
pronunciations it became dick pucks yeah
so like you know the pic the the I sound
also turns into a different sound it's
funny because New Zealand and Australia
have these very specific nuances between
their accents and so I wonder if an
Australian version will work as well
there's one more thing to look up the
Key of Awesome
later that same evening yeah these are
parody sketches okay yeah after five
minutes early just like the text of
everything this guy put dad's made it
sound so of that day one he's also got
this wig on - it's like the guy in the
video has an ever worsening yeah there
you go over the course of the sketches
well it's a really well put together
sketch I mean go with like good
different colors yeah yeah stepping on
riding on yeah you know hardening it you
know how artists yeah there are a lot of
really clever
it's got into having and sharing it with
your wife and the absurdity of enhancing
it - the third one where you're making
fun of essentially the salt exposure but
not intentionally causing it or what it
is like we got deck picks yeah
removed and a Vigo and banging the first
one that it might be real yeah the first
thing that is the most good and I feel
like that's how these kinds of parodies
often begin is the first one is just
down-to-earth enough to almost have an
uncanny quality and then the next one's
again broader and yeah pretty soon it's
just like you're sitting there
anticipating what's every possible deck
joke they can make that was that was
hilarious the best dick jokes I've ever
heard sometimes you could get no context
for these and this was the time where no
context was absolutely a benefit
especially to have that opening text be
like really throwing you for a loop all
right well guys subscribe to the Key of
Awesome yeah and why not subscribe to
the guy who put this compilation
together yeah ultimate videos 278 yeah
subscribers that is one of those videos
where I'm just gonna be the new pitcher
it's gonna be the new thing I'm gonna be
showing this was a revelation thank you
Andrew Nickerson NICUs and Nicholson for
sending over that video to us dude I
hope you enjoy building your LEGO sets
well you watch these kinds of videos my
dude let me know how the progress of
getting that house is going and let me
know how the status of grinder is going
for you too um I believe you're straight
but before you decide to settle down
again I would try out the grinder app
honestly you know clearly you got a
thing for dicks so it's a great place to
find a dick to hang out on and maybe get
some lovin see I brought a full circles
full circles Andrew big dickerson
Nickerson thanks buddy